so it's basically it's basically like
germinate like sending out seeds to form
new galaxies yeah yeah maybe you're
right dude it's the [ __ ] circle of
life
face you should stop
you should see my black hole
[Music]
we're gonna get a little sci-fi
something happened in space that has
never happened before it was a scam yeah
space is a huge scab space is a scam
it's just one giant Nigerian prince so
uh this thing happened basically
um when black holes swallow Stars
usually like it'll go and then like
pieces of the star get spit out as like
the thing gets stuck in so um for the
first time ever in 2018
that happened where they observed the
star getting sucked into a black hole so
you just see a bunch of light and like
it just goes in right for three years
nothing happened and then three years
later they observed that same black hole
spitting out remnants of that same star
whoa and that's like the first time
that's ever been observed or recorded or
anything that's [ __ ] time I don't
know what it means there's no idea like
what the [ __ ] you know like they're
really just reading data in waves but
that's the first of its kind what's up
black hole
um go ahead Colleen that's a good
question right I've seen Interstellar
but black hole black holes really the
the what is interesting thing because
it's a theory right it's it's no one's
ever been to a black hole no one can
really tangibly like touch it but it's
basically a reading that shows there's a
point where all matter is being
compressed into such a pressurized point
that nothing can escape it yeah even
time he's only seen it by way of gravity
right yeah okay Matthew McConaughey
escapes a black hole basically they did
say with Interstellar the depiction of a
black hole and Interstellar was the best
depiction of the theoretical black
people I also saw so there's that DVD
extra documentary I think in the 70s
where they flew in just kidding Journey
to the Center of the world or something
they they flew into a black hole and
then they went hyperspeed and they flew
out at the other end yeah but you gotta
go Hyper Speed though who did that it
was documentary like in the 70s right I
think it was called Journey to the
Center of the I think that's Event
Horizon no Adventures
that movie
yeah but yeah for the first time they
didn't know that anything so normally
nothing ever escapes the black hole Yeah
except these stars but some movies it
goes to like another universe or
something yeah because of the parallel
thing yeah but we don't know or the
Wormhole Concept in general right yeah
nobody nobody knows what it'll do to
organic like understanding if you like
enter it but don't you just get dropped
off into like a library where you can
[ __ ] do Morse code and [ __ ] yeah yeah
you go into the was it the Tesseract
yeah the Tesseract yeah what's her name
his daughter I don't know she got a dude
names
dude it's so good everyone keeps telling
me how good it is me and bar are gonna
watch it because he's obviously never
seen it
I've seen it a while ago
wow no no I'm still thinking because I
learned about it I've never been so
uninspired to continue conversation I
think I think they said there was like
uh the minute time freezes it starts
like eight different timelines see now
you just you were literally [ __ ]
down information
once you go to the point where time
stops there's the first timeline of you
going there and stopping the second one
is you going into the black hole and
then there's a third one like it just
because so many things happen once time
actually stops so one is you're actually
going back in time
and it's like yeah it's like that's like
when they say we invent time travel
then like the world explodes there's no
history there's no future there's no who
said that Doc Brown
because you don't know where people are
from yeah it's like here then now never
you know or the world will explode
because some [ __ ] just blew it
up in the past and he goes back all
right because now it's all all the time
everything right all at once everything
everywhere all at once Michelle yeah I
never seen that that looks oh you would
love it that looks too no you would love
it dude that's too smart though as
someone that loves Interstellar you
should see that movie right you've never
seen her story yeah Interstellar feels
like the dumbed down version of that
no no it's not it's not but I hear it's
a less colorful version yeah uh yeah
everything ever all at once is a fun
movie I just watched five minutes and
they're just hanging out on a laundromat
and I turned it off that's my peoples
man yeah bro
you got two Asians two Asian he's too
Asian they're a bit of laundry and white
girlfriend in the beginning yeah
we're the same
so with what you know about black holes
does that mean anything to you that they
were able to see remnants of a star at
eight three years ago pop out I am your
expert I was trying to Rattle My Brain
to see if I remembered anything else but
how you come up with information I gotta
answer this question is that why you
were buffering for so long it's like a
magic eight ball Real Player just stuck
in college Years he's like ask again
what I'm curious about though is is was
that the like how many stars of that
black hole eaten previously like maybe
it was full and so I had to spit this
one out or was it the first like star
that's a black hole ate yeah or do we
know it's the exact same Stars right
yeah
because it could have been like 500 year
old star at eight well I mean that would
be even more remarkable I think the
assumption that it's the same one from
three years ago is the easier thing to
assume but if you said it was from even
older that's even bigger of a
breakthrough or how how is the star
coming out is it the release of gravity
or is it the the initiation of gravity
somewhere else pulling the Stars yeah
that's a suspension of the black hole's
gravity for that to make it happen yeah
usually all they've seen so far is that
while this star gets sucked in the
action of it sucking in kind of Ricochet
[ __ ] all over the place
that's usually it's instant they've
never seen it a black hole not do
anything and then just [ __ ] just pops
out that's enough whoa what if it was
just a speck on their lens
for a long time and that [ __ ] go crazy
yeah
because isn't that astronomy though
astronomy looks at a 2D image and then
they look it up and they go oh this
planet has these these gases yeah like
how do you know from a 2D image what it
has yeah I was looking up some of the
new pictures though those are crazy
oh the oh from the telescope oh yeah we
have like eight new pictures from some
[ __ ] Multiverse yeah but but the
photo was taken like 16 years ago and
finally yeah because of the light yeah
yeah yeah something of that nature but
they look crazy well those people that
read those graphs yeah they get horny
off those things oh yeah so when I uh so
my last the expert is back
look at Colleen's face
lab class was studying uh like brain
activity on mice and then they would
have mice like [ __ ] eat [ __ ] [ __ ] or
do whatever and then so you're like
studying the so they're attach these
little [ __ ]
the story gets crazier as we go yeah
continue we're clearly not all
scientists and you see all these graphs
right of like marking where all the
activity is you were getting horny no
for me
so they're saying like sideways
scratches mean this or upward scratches
mean this but then when my professor
comes in she's like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy because then she'll notice
like wow these rats are doing new [ __ ]
do you Professor sounds hot
oh my God
so it's like it's like reading the
Matrix yeah the community I thought he
was really gonna say some like crazy
[ __ ] and he was like oh she was rubbing
her name
Bart Winton
the Vivid University
I let the brainwave I love the brain
waves you're talking about was gonna
show the horniness yeah that's but it
was really just hurts my professor
getting a horny over [ __ ] brain waves
I'm like who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] the
telescope the new telescope images all
the astronomers go crazy yeah they got
crazy and then they look and they go now
we can tell what gas is I mean how how
do you know from a 2D image and I think
with black holes it's a total 2D image
that they see yeah and it's all like
they call them hypotheses I just call
them assumptions whatever now they're
assuming that it's the same star that
they ate three years ago but then for it
to do that it has to have a suspension
of gravity like their gravity pull has
did that means the black hole has the
ability to like lessen its gravity yeah
or trapping the light or whatever it may
be or we eat and then we [ __ ] they call
it they call it like a uh they call it
like a Celestial burp it's like it's
like the black hole is basically what
looks like burping it's a little star so
you're saying like one thing went inside
three years later a couple smaller
things came out
like debris from the Star yeah
so some of it escaped which is uh that's
basically first because then that kind
of goes against the the existing Theory
and it's probably so [ __ ] far away
that whatever [ __ ] burp they saw was
from 30 years ago anyways
which takes a long time though to travel
to you yeah but we say it's a first how
long have we've been even like looking
at black holes 100 years I don't know
what about the concept that like uh you
know I'm thinking about [ __ ] really
really nice child [ __ ] like The Lion
King and Mufasa explaining the circle of
life no it's definitely the past Kings
yeah but exactly but you know the idea
of like eating an antelope and then or
whatever the animal becomes the grass
when it dies blah blah so there's like
Circle of Life concept right right what
if there's like [ __ ] black holes are
these giant Celestial beings that are
like going out like eating old stars and
[ __ ] not new ones almost like planting
seeds and then now that's the new Galaxy
so they're germinating it's not yeah
it's not just about like [ __ ] out
the old star it's about like consuming
something that needs to end its life and
then putting something else out it's
beautiful that is beautiful so it's
basically it's basically is like Germany
like sending out seeds to form new
galaxies yeah yeah maybe you're right
dude it's the [ __ ] circle of life
if that's if
it
stop
you should see my black hole black holes
in general are just super infinitely
interesting there's always some weird
[ __ ] with them there was I was reading
some other things showing what happens
when two black holes meet have you seen
that is that just a like a made-up thing
right it sounds like the start of a joke
no like they were able to observe like
so when whenever you're observing a
black hole you're really just looking at
the effect around it and that's how you
know it's there yeah but it's not one of
those things that you just see a [ __ ]
hole like you don't really see it but
then they're saying like when when two
of them are within range from each other
the the time in between is being Twisted
you ever heard of that Holy we gotta
study black hole like the energy between
two magnets that are on the wrong sides
there's something that's going on that's
invisible and yet very very very real
that's how they discovered black hole
right that there was some sort of
gravitational pull that was happening
but there was no planet or stars for
them for that cause yeah so that's how
they
I guess discovered it first and then
they they started to do a little more
research yeah so what it's pretty cool
that like to find something that you
thought I'm sure finding any new info
about a thing you've been looking at for
maybe 100 years it's pretty cool yeah
they should send like a satellite into a
black hole with a with a GoPro on yeah
how close are these things they gotta be
hella far dude's never gonna get it back
though it's gone yeah like our [ __ ]
satellites that we sent out like 30
years ago are finally passing by like
Jupiter right now you know what I mean
like it's it's gonna take a minute to
get to a black hole but then it's also
gone once it gets there right so they
should they should put like you know the
latest technology like all the newest go
like GoPro 9 yeah some cell phones like
5G LT whatever and then like have it
burst out all this info as soon as it
gets in yeah with the ring light we
gotta get a ring light a selfie stick
have it like send out emit like whatever
all the photos and do it as soon I think
you should write a letter to NASA
explaining your idea yeah I think they
might hire you so they'll understand
I'll put on I'll twitch it throw the
budget yeah don't give them a budget and
then just tell them what they need to
send out and then I'll make sure to
earmark like 10 million just for us to
talk about it oh yeah that first meeting
is pretty pricey
[Music]
foreign